welcome to deconstructing chatbots I'm
Priyanka Vergara and in this episode we
will learn how to integrate dialogue
flow agent with ml api's depending on
what your conversational AIU skis is
your users may want to upload an image
to the chat application and expect a
response that guides them further in
that conversation this is exactly what
we will learn today we will be seeing
how to create a dialogue flow agent that
fulfills an image request by calling the
Google vision API we will be using the
same django front-end application that
we created in the previous episode and
add image upload functionality to it if
you've not watched the previous episode
I highly recommend you start there all
right so here's what we are building the
user ends up on our chat application and
interacts with it the chat pod responds
with the greeting defining the two
things it can do setting up appointments
and understanding invoices we've already
seen setting up appointments in the
previous episodes so we'll just skip
that for now and just ask for
understanding our bill users prompted to
upload the image of their invoice once
they upload that image we display it on
our front-end and return back the text
detected in that image by processing it
through the vision API now from
architectural standpoint here's how this
is working the chat app will be served
on App Engine the app is built in Python
using django which is a python-based
free and open source of app framework
app engine will interact with cloud
sequel for any database requests the
users upload the files we will save them
to Google Cloud storage and the app will
interact with our dialogue flow agent
we are the dialogue flow API the example
uses the appointment scheduler that we
created in the third episode and
enhanced in the 8th episode to integrate
with Google Calendar today we are
enhancing it further by adding an
integration with vision API now with
that background let's dive
and see how to make it work check out
the link in the description below to
download the source code for this
application make sure to follow the
setup steps I'm going to show you the
main part that makes the integration
with the vision API possible but you can
read the elaborate setup instructions in
the readme file first let's look at the
dialogue flow console I'm still using
the previously created appointment
scheduler agent from episode 3 we will
start from the Welcome intent modify the
response so that the users clearly know
that our chat bot can handle appointment
scheduling and invoice related questions
next create an intent to capture users
input if they are contacting us about
their invoice provide a static response
telling the user to upload a file create
an intent that takes the file input once
the user has provided the file we
extract the filename using a custom
entity if you don't know what custom
entities are check out episode 6 and for
the response enable the fulfillment
check out the front-end django code to
see how to handle the plumbing from
front-end to dialogue flow now let's see
the fulfillment GS file scroll down to
the intent map section and to find the
new intent map for file upload in the
function apply a mel pass the agent and
declare a variable to get hold of the
file name that the user has uploaded we
can do that by writing agent dot
parameters dot file name then call a
function to handle vision API requests
you pass the bucket name and the file
name to create the GCS bucket pad then
you create the client to call the vision
API on this client we call the text
detection method and pass the GCS bucket
path from where the file will be pulled
at that point we have a resulting JSON
with all the detected text since for
this example we are only interested in
the text description I created a list of
all the text
descriptions and returned it as is back
in our intent map we are taking the
returned value and sending it as a
response to the user as you can imagine
the possibilities are endless with an
integration like this once you haven't
working you can pretty much change the
vision API methods to identify labels
landmarks faces and more you can also
use the same concept and integrate with
other ml api's like NLP vision
translation jobs and even your custom ml
api's that you built through Auto ml I
cannot wait to hear from you how you're
applying this integration tell us all
about your use case in the comments
below today we learned how to create a
custom dialogue flow fronting on App
Engine using Django framework and
integrated it with vision API on the
backend I hope to see you in the next
episode of deconstructing chatbots
if you like this video and would like to
see more such content don't forget to
Like and subscribe to our Channel
[Music]